greetings from podcast village Monday
the 27th of May the podcast is brought
to you by manscaped let me tell you
something no more anxiety this summer's
coming and you don't want your balls
sweating and your dick smelling like a
[ __ ] sewer that's why you gotta trim
around the edges uncle Joey's here to
tell you don't cut your dick off [ __ ] oh
the suffering ends now with manscaped
you could get it done without the pain
they got precision tools for the Family
Jewels manscaped has redesigned the
electric razor what we're gonna do is
this alright Church listeners get 20%
off your first order when you use promo
code church at manscape dot-com let me
explain something manscape is the future
no more walking around with hairy balls
and hair coming out of the [ __ ] no more
manscape is gonna help you out there
invention is the lawnmower a handheld
razor with skin safe technology so won't
snick or snag your little butts your
ball sack or your [ __ ] love stick and
now the church family like I said get
20% off your first order when you use
promo code church at manscape calm and
if you order the perfect package which
I'll tell you about at the end of the
show
they'll also throw in a free travel bag
when you use promo code Church CH you
are CH that's manscape com use promo
code church for 20% off your first order
keep your balls clean and your [ __ ]
love stick shaved with manscape com the
church is also brought to you by on it
islet is the way to go when it comes to
supplements on it's the only company
I've been [ __ ] her for the last like
eight years from the protein shake to
the shroom tech immune to shrimp export
to the Maine [ __ ] alpha brain
which is a bunch of nootropics put
together hope you think clearer get you
a little bit more focused and if it
doesn't work I don't know give you a
hundred percent money-back guarantee and
they don't want the product who all
stands behind their supplements like
that nobody odd it does so gonna holla
calm right now
press in church and get 10% off your
first order delivered to your house kick
this [ __ ] mealy what's
happening you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey here my main jersey native [ __ ]
Bruce Springsteen I got Jimmy Florentine
this [ __ ] exactly you know if
your true Jersey guy you didn't like
Springsteen though if you were a metal
guy he was you know you didn't like him
[ __ ] Springsteen [ __ ] I like them later
on
yeah later on you learn to appreciate
him well kind of older but we're growing
up there people drove you crazy like
they would you know they would just
drive you crazy with that same [ __ ]
Springsteen I got tortured as a kid
because of my musical tastes and I
always got trumped because I always
suddenly pulled out the Beatle card or
the Springsteen card yeah and then when
John Lennon got died when he got shot I
was so [ __ ] happy for today because I
didn't have to hear those scumbags no
more with this same ol because you
couldn't say nothing I want to see
decent last night [ __ ] great show
yeah but they're not better than the
Beatles and you heard that [ __ ] growing
up yeah my beginnings of music from like
74 so John Lennon got shot in 79 or
Haiti that's all you heard growing up in
but then that [ __ ] is to be those and he
couldn't argue it they would Trump you
had nowhere to go yet a Beatle and then
if you Jersey was all about Springsteen
it's like I had a friend that I was
friends it's his first grade he was a
big metalhead and he met this really hot
chick and he started dating there and he
hated Springsteen too when he went to
see Springsteen with her I didn't talk
him oh yeah my people thought I'd talk
to alma mater I stopped talking yeah I'm
like how do you be trying sighs we call
the cops on you we tell you enough to
cook them put the cops on and [ __ ] and
then when you call we put Bruce
Springsteen on have Bruce bell yeah you
like Bruce here born to run start
running you're [ __ ]
I got bumper stickers made up there is
no reason for Bruce Springsteen and the
boss is a total loss and I used to put
them on people's bumpers say I cruise
parking lots and if I saw somewhat of
Bruce Springsteen bumper sticker I put
that over it on their car I was out of
my mind I'd put him on every sign I'd be
driving around put him on signs put him
everywhere I got like 500 over made and
I'm thinking to this day I'm like why
did I do that for what reason what why
do you think music has such like a
emotional he's just a guy
while you guys hate him you guys like
actively like sounds like oh I just
don't like you understand that hated a
couple people they just didn't have to
be musically right I tell you what the
first person I had more hatred than life
for Richard Gere like I had a personal
vendetta against Richard Gere cuz I was
starting to get into the groove you
starting to hit on girls and [ __ ] you
like women and every woman was in love
with Richard Gere when I was starting to
sprout every woman then he [ __ ] came
on American Gigolo and shown his ass
yeah and that was the end you couldn't
compete with that ass so I was like I'm
gonna stab Richard [ __ ] get when I saw
him in the city I was all coked up and I
was given a legal life and my friends
like let it go I'm like this
[ __ ] he relationships up all
over the world because women think that
actually gonna get Richard Gere I'm
lying to you the first guy that was
gonna go down with Donny Osmond I was
gonna shoot Donny on when I was 12 he's
the first one that [ __ ] my game up and
then he disappeared for a while so [ __ ]
him
and then Richard Gere showed up and I
was gonna beat him but I saw office and
a gentleman that was pretty good and I
said I'll give him a pass yeah and by 85
I was okay with Richard Gere well for
four or five years I was on the [ __ ]
Richard Gere if you listen to Richard
Gere you're lucky pretty woman
[ __ ] yeah I don't know you just
had this hatred man if you were in the
hard rock and heavy metal you were
against everything else cuz you know so
you just like too bad anybody that liked
any kind of rock music cuz you hung out
with a different crowd at school they
became in an ac/dc shirt you hung out
with the burnouts and the guys that
smoke cigarettes and hung and then the
other for jocks or whatever didn't like
you and look they'd look down at you
like [ __ ] you or if they were
Springsteen sure like he hated him even
more so does annoy you now that if they
play like both of the ac/dc and
Springsteen on like a classic rock
station together this isn't the same
thing no I don't mind it you know like I
said as we get older me and Joe it's
just like alright you know he's had some
good song say I don't know what was
wrong with me then okay it's really
crazy couple weeks ago I went back to
Jersey and I brought back these strong
edibles and I went out with my brother
and I gave him a hundred milligram I
kept telling there were 50
the house so now we're stuck for the
[ __ ] thing so he goes did you bring
it I gave it to him and he got [ __ ] up
and they told me and we goes nice
thinking high and eat Domino's Pizza you
can't lead Domino's Pizza you're from my
neighborhood
it just isn't allowed I get that you
wouldn't even be you just would be
ostracized didn't even have one in your
neighborhood I don't even know probably
but yeah that you put your you'll get is
one years old not be talked right that's
it that's is that serious if that makes
sense to me back then we hold our
[ __ ] values and that's what a lot of
people don't understand a lot of people
don't get it's not just one time it's a
belief it's a belief it's like yesterday
my or two days ago Thursday my buddy
posted on Facebook and I said I missed
you at Roma's my friends still go to
Roma's pizza after 40 years and they
wouldn't go anywhere else and I asked
Charlie from Roma's ago who still comes
in he knows everybody even though they
live in all parts of Jersey they stopped
there once a week to get a slice
that's the loyalty you have and they
don't need pizza anywhere else anywhere
else that's crazy
you know I went back to Roma and I
refused to eat pizza here since I've
gone back to Rome since I've been back
Jersey my daughter goes to that pizza
parlor I cannae
last week I want had a meatball sandwich
I don't know why like I'm done like my
friends we just would not do anything
like that like they would not listen to
[ __ ] music that wasn't authorized
like that's not even in their [ __ ]
brain like it's not even in that brain I
don't know how many parties are
authorized I don't know how many parties
I went and I saw John Crowley just break
a Bruce Springsteen out just break it
just throwing out of the [ __ ] guys
like if it was playing he would just go
up and throw it because you knew like if
you invited these people over they
weren't gonna tolerate that
it's just the word that's just the way
it is I was doing construction at
time enough Springsteen song came on the
radio we're putting the roof up or
whatever and as soon as that Reyes
Springsteen song came on I would [ __ ]
jump off the roof to shut that off
that's how crazy it was I would run if I
was in the middle putting a piece of
sheetrock up I'd [ __ ] stop everything
and run to shut that off it was quick it
was crazy how we boycotted things I
still have a personal boycott boycott
things and I don't say dick like Tom
Hanks I boycotted Tom Hanks for crying
on the Oscars when he won Philadelphia
really like I didn't watch another one
of his movies took me ten years keep I
personally like banned Tom Hanks from my
life and that's what you have to do some
time like that's the [ __ ] the dead
like I don't know why I just get mad
sometimes I go that's it it's over yeah
and I just won't do it no more like I
couldn't believe I got when I went back
for this movie and this sign I tell you
this with pain in my heart I tell you
this with pain in my heart because this
is how stoic and old-school I am when I
went back to New York the first place I
went there was 3:30 42nd Street to get
wardrobe done think of the address I'm
Tanya 3:30 see you're all the way out by
like no I was a block away from me to
have it right so after I got wardrobe I
went Elia what I'm gonna do my time I
looked up I went for a walk and I walk
down 42nd Street I made a left and I
walked up and if you walk two or three
blocks up there's an Olive Garden yeah
and it caught my eye
and I'm not ashamed to tell you I stood
there for 20 minutes wishing death on
every tourist that walked in there
because I don't know I really I really
cannot comprehend like that's how stupid
I am but I cannot comprehend how a
person goes to New York and goes to a
[ __ ] alley yeah I do not understand
that it's a man who know there's a
Chevys across the street from Chevy's
across the street yeah I do not
understand how I could go to Long Island
and get on an elevator with a kid with a
Domino's box in this parent right next
to him I can't tell you how much I
hold back and beating up the parent for
letting the kiddie the Domino's when
he's in the [ __ ] capital of Pizza
like you're in the capital of pizza like
I can't even comprehend that type of
[ __ ]
yeah like even if you're not hungry for
a pizza you gotta eat a pizza out of
respect for being that even though it's
out I mean it sounds a little silly when
you think about it does this sort of
like strictness help you guys even
though Domino's is a silly eating this
discipline that's where it starts
it's that discipline of little things
it's the little things that get you to
the bigger commitments so if you start
another dumb thing there was a club
named quintessence when I was growing up
there was a bar named quintessence and
the Richfield on the way up who was sort
of like a disco right I went to that
parking lot one time and in the parking
lot we were snow coke and I told the
drivers like for gorillas in the car and
two gorillas had to go in there to pick
up chicks and there was something about
the front of that place that I did not
like I did not like the doorman I didn't
like how girls were acting when they
were walking in and I told the driver
let's get the [ __ ] out of here the kid
who was driving and for a year I
boycotted quintessence it was my little
power play when people would come to me
and go you go to quintesson I go no and
they would drop the look on their face
would be priceless and I did it on
purpose to show people you don't have to
go to that dump where Joan mary's type
of mother [ __ ] we're from a
neighborhood bar we don't go to those
point I got one age I decided that I
didn't want to go to clubs no more rock
clubs I liked like the bubble factory
what's there was the one but so fact I'm
so fresh all factory yeah the soap
factory I kind of dug but there was a
lot of [ __ ] in there too
yeah but I went to see a couple bands
and they're not bad I walked out a
Twisted Sister there and I saw Aerosmith
there you do know Aerosmith played there
yeah cuz I know they play and yeah
are they and they play like the found
casino and Jersey on that same run I saw
him there they were all [ __ ] out all
[ __ ] up but I used to go like I made a
point
Pagoda quintessence ladies night
whatever and people would lose their
mind until this day people look at me go
that's right you never what the
quintessence like I just refused to go
to quintessence you're telling these
people like I your bamm-bamm you're
banned from from my life I'm not gonna
go to your bar no I just made a decision
I just make a decision one day that I'm
not [ __ ] doing that [ __ ] I'm not I
don't want to be like everybody else and
do that [ __ ] neither don't do it smart
why be like every while live your life
and be like everybody else
yeah why live your life and have an
earring and the goatee and the cap and
trying to be cool and you never saying
like I hate all that people actually
think they look good like the people
don't think they fit in crazy I never
really wanted to fit in if you if you
grew up listening a hard rock a heavy
metal you were not trying to fit in you
without trying to feel an absence to
this day if you like that music you're
not trying to fit in I think I mean I
guess that's good though yeah I never
wanted to really be in I always thought
I wanted to be in but I knew I wasn't
like right like I didn't lie when I was
a kid and everybody all the kids in
school was hell
Santana and I would look at them and go
I don't know what the [ __ ] you laughing
about
I can never make me laugh once yeah so I
knew there was something wrong with me
already and then growing up any popular
show I remember when friends was popular
and whatever I went watch I wouldn't
watch one second of it oh my gosh no I
guess y'all we got a new haircut I'm
like whoo oh yeah I know what everybody
was talking about I'm like I never I
will never watch that ever
you just don't know I'm the same way I
didn't watch Game of Thrones everyone
everyone goes crazy even Star Wars
they're more stalking about story I
never why don't ever saw one ever saw
one vt I never any T and ever watched
that yet I don't like nothing specially
the same with me nothing space relays
I'm amazed once I see a Martian you lost
it's right I mean I watched a couple of
like lost in space as a little kid I
watched it huh no space as a kid but I
didn't watch Star Trek
daddy neither I refused to watch [ __ ]
Star Trek as soon as it came on Batman
rolled boom Oh Star Trek I refuse to
watch all those [ __ ] show yeah same
here it just refused as comics though do
you ever feel like you need to watch any
of these things or listen just to be
able to reference them and what other
things know if you're real comic I don't
know why you're watching anything for me
to tell anyone
that's all so yeah yeah a real comedian
before DVD RN and binge watching I
didn't watch TV a legit first of all I
didn't I didn't watch TV probably from
86 to when I went to prison that's when
I started watching on Sundays we watch
America's Most Wanted in the president
huh and married with children that was
it that was it I'd watch TV on Sunday
nights and then once I started counting
I didn't watch TV try and move to LA and
I started auditioning for TV shows and
that forced me to watch those shows TV
was out of my life when I got it when I
first got to come here sold my Sony
Trinitron that was the first thing I did
to get the discipline down I think I
sold it for 40 bucks
Wow that was it right TV I don't need TV
yeah I did doing comedy yet sign a Night
Live I go I never swatch I was always
working I don't you shouldn't be what I
never I was never home to watch it on a
Saturday so I didn't know what was going
on right that mean that makes sense but
I mean and I guess it's also sometimes I
don't like it like some comics they have
jokes about a song that's out or about a
TV show and I guess some of it's good
but all you like yeah means like right
now you talk about the Game of Thrones
finale which I've no watch any of that
either it's like there's gonna be six
other comics on the show too probably
gonna have a joke about that so why
would I want to go okay like I need to
know about that cuz everyone's talking
about it
okay I think it goes back for me because
I was thinking about this for me it was
more like when you see a [ __ ] Mexican
dude will mow on the lawn right go up to
him and ask him if he knows of graeme of
thrones' ask him if he gives a [ __ ]
about Archie the kid from England the
[ __ ] ugly [ __ ] kid that was born
to the Prince of England
[ __ ] Reagan whatever Markley whatever
[ __ ] nameless asked him if they want
the city avenges they don't know nothing
about that gentleman about that like and
that's what him agrument how he is they
don't have time for stupidity you know I
grew up I was very ashamed this last
time about New York because when I was
raised in New York City the first thing
your mom told you and you walked the
streets was look straight ahead and
don't [ __ ] around I can't believe how
many New Yorkers I saw looking at their
[ __ ] phone I wish I could smack them
all in one hand this is the worst
[ __ ] thing going in the world right
now this takes people's attention just
takes your [ __ ] time this is why when
I go on the road I don't bring social
media with me once I'm on the road
there's there's no social media would I
have Twitter on this phone but no face
yeah I got my emergency [ __ ] email
but that's it because I've seen what
it's done to people people are [ __ ]
done with social media
it went from posting one thing to
posting the psychological problems
though social media is at an all-time
[ __ ] low and it's not social medias
fault it's our fault for letting
ourselves get caught up you know I'm
saying I use it to promote dates and to
keep in touch with the fan base from
though from the church I don't use it to
tell [ __ ] people my problems or your
your policy it's gone somewhere
completely [ __ ] different well I
think it's just people that's where
they're living their lives now like a
lot of people on like whenever I'm on
the diet I do i watch people i watch I
look for food videos on YouTube and
there's a new thing now where people are
eating like 10 cheeseburgers and I'm
like it's called a call like a mukbang
like the e like a whole stack of food
and they have like millions of views and
then people are just living their entire
lives on the computer now if you're if
you don't go online for five days and
you go back on you didn't miss one thing
in this one thing do you miss 120 they
said 20% of people are on Twitter in the
whole world and only 10% actually engage
with people so 80% I have 17 people on
my family and three of them are on
Twitter
and none of them post anything they just
follow whatever news organizations to
see what's going on most of the people
have know what my friend got some
Twitter beef or another comic I go you
realize 2,000 people know what's going
on in this whole world right I go no one
knows what the [ __ ] going on I go
don't plate it at 2,000 people but do
you think that it's on everyone's radar
it's not who gives a [ __ ] cuz we're all
on it every day or a lot what kills me
the most about this thing that we go
through right now with social media is
like I had to say something to somebody
a couple weeks ago I really like this
girl she's come to a couple shows and
stuff and she emails me once every 10
days about Thailand and how beautiful it
is and one Saturday I just checked
Twitter and she had 20 [ __ ] tweets in
a row there's two people that I don't
know how they're living their lives you
know people always go all Joey you got
some mile and there's [ __ ] stories
that cuz I'm not I wasn't raised on the
[ __ ] television or raised on a phone
I was raised on the street I was raised
living life experiences not reading
about somebody doing mushrooms or
reading about so I lived it you know I'm
saying like I lived it I never had to
read about it and then they'll do it to
try to be like I didn't know anything
about that I lived for now like and I
still live from now I feel bad when I
see people constantly and you see them
constantly okay all you have to do is
look at the threads and see what you
missed for six hours and you're like
this person has not stopped you go to a
[ __ ] concert what do you see people
with their phones up taping why are you
taping
what are you taping what is it gonna do
for you to show somebody at work why are
you taping why are you taping you're not
watching you're not getting the full
[ __ ] experience you're not [ __ ]
getting the full experience of what life
is throwing at you put that [ __ ] this
is the worst thing that they could be
created for us yeah this is the worst
thing it simplifies people nobody you
know like I just stopped
with the tax like if you text me you
might as well shoot yourself she's not
gonna get nowhere like don't text me
cuz you're not gonna get no it's over I
disconnected the [ __ ] thing it's over
like I get certain [ __ ] it's over
like every day I shed more and more of
the phone or social media like I'm down
to Thursdays now right I used to [ __ ]
around on Fridays I eliminated Fridays
because it's taken too much time I
noticed that it was taken and it's not
me I see what it's doing to people
you're killing your life you're not
living your life you're looking at
something and then you look down a post
something stupid yeah like something
that has no value in our world or in
your life at all you know the other I
went somewhere to eat that was like
let's take a picture I go No
why am i doing what everybody else does
forget this yeah I mean it's it I was
trying to do a few weeks ago something
on Instagram the picture wouldn't fit
and I'm trying to shrink it down I'm
telling my friend Johanna and I'm like
what the [ __ ] am I just wasted 25
minutes to try to shrink it cuz it
doesn't fit on Instagram like what am i
doing my life who gives a [ __ ] up I post
us or not our kids getting phones like I
didn't get a phone until I was in middle
school and that way it was just a brick
phone like the nokia old ones our kids
young kids like elementary school
getting phones now my kids eight he's
gonna be nine he doesn't even know he's
not getting a phone for a while he's not
even asking for one really I figured
they'd be asking by like four or five he
doesn't his cousin who's a couple years
old at him he's got the phone and now
they have like their relay it's affected
their relationship because whenever they
see each other he's just looking at the
phone playing a game and my son just
sitting next to him going hey hey you
don't want to talk to him but he's just
buried in the phone
ya know I would be if I was a kid I
forced my daughter out of the house
everything today it started drizzle I
still forced her out I walked into the
park myself for an hour and a half I
forced her out so there's no I want her
to live to say you know I was talking to
my wife last night about going to that
[ __ ] school where she goes to school
at and saying that I want the kids to
put together like a school new
so they have to deliver papers each kid
has to deliver a paper on their block
and you get the kids writing and going
out I think that a lot of people don't
have that I have noticed a lot of the
people that come on the podcast The
Sharper people have a paper route I
noticed that kids that had a paper route
are sharper [ __ ] kids because they
had that that contact with humans
younger age you know how to wheel and
deal one thing I noticed the last month
especially is that adults and that slick
anymore
what's that you say I'm moving to town
here what Ben Affleck might have yeah
yeah yeah he tells the cop next time
don't take pictures down the corner from
my house be slicker than a 5th grader
and whenever he said slicker than
whatever this country has forgotten how
to be slick I see it from dealing with
people dealing would be people aren't
slick no more then I slick like five my
six-year-old is slicker than most adult
today they don't know how to fit nothing
in they don't know how to wheel and deal
they don't know the counter you know
like when I was a kid and I come to your
door do you want the Sunday paper no I
used that I use that paper out to sell
all my [ __ ] like if I was a CYO
basketball player all right if you don't
want the Sunday paper you're buying the
[ __ ] stick right and if you're not
buying a sticker yeah you're buying
something from and I'm gonna come at you
on every day until you buy something
from me and when I realize you're not
gonna buy something for me I'll put you
on a list and on Halloween when we throw
eggs your house is gonna get bombarded
too much luck yeah hope you work people
you understood how to work people I want
my daughters had that same thing how to
work people and that's how you learn all
this [ __ ] so I'm going for that [ __ ]
school to pitch him for her first grade
that all those get five or six first
graders and give them extra credit make
them write second graders third graders
fourth graders fifth grade even if I
have to walk down the block deliver
those papers yeah and to ask for the
quarter whatever the [ __ ] it is because
we're missing out we're missing out I
see kids missing out a lot of things
that I had growing up that I
I'm happy I didn't miss on them paper
routes working you know when it's no
[ __ ] shoveling people out I used to
make 100 bucks every time easily
no absolutely hundred a yard stick out
[ __ ] a shovel me and my buddies you
want to drink today you want to smoke
pilots we're going back on every door
knock on door 20 bucks 25 bucks 30 we
have forgotten that we that is these are
unknown secrets and people when they
hear this they go I never thought of
that because you're not slick we've lost
that gift it's like I was telling you
before the podcast started and we'll
call my buddy Mike Duffy right now Mike
Duffy was the leader that [ __ ] I didn't
come up with it I told you in 1976 for
the the 200th anniversary of the [ __ ]
whatever we were down there walking
around and we saw a parking lot that was
empty and the restaurant was closed so
we went we borrowed a [ __ ] bolt
cutter from a cop like we went up to a
cop can sing can we borrow bolt cutter
he's like forties are somebody tied my
bicycle the cop was looking at the
Hudson River
we went and cut the [ __ ] chain and we
charged four dollars to park is it legal
no it's not illegal but it's kids being
slick it's just kids being slick and if
you start at that age how to flip a
[ __ ] buck when you get older you know
how to be [ __ ] slick kids today they
have no paper I think I know quaaludes
they got no hits a hat you have no way
to learn about business at a young age
13 and 14 I'm not trying to be funny I'm
telling you that that's the god truth
you don't understand the value of a
dollar how to buy something for two
dollars and sell it for four whatever
the [ __ ] it is when I was a kid I sold
everything I remember I remember getting
on a plane one time with my mother and
stepfather going to Puerto Rico and the
first class they used to give you
shampoos and hand creams and me sitting
there going I'm gonna take I took a puke
bag and I put all the perfumes because I
would sell them on Broadway right like I
was that much of a [ __ ] bench when I
was a [ __ ] kid when I was shooting
that movie in Jersey we had to shoot in
a banquet hall and I was sitting in one
of those Hollywood chairs and I was
looking up and they had chandeliers and
they were like little jazz
and I'ma being a kid gold somewhere and
stealin the [ __ ] gems off the
chandelier thinking there were diamonds
and saw them on Broadway and people
telling me to get the [ __ ] out of it it
was the heart that mattered I was still
I always was a wheeler-dealer I don't
know if you get that from being from
Jersey I don't know what the [ __ ] when I
moved to Jersey those kids made a mint
they stole something every day the
common denominator we would go to
Secaucus and cut punks those things that
you light on fire yah yah yah yah to
kill the mosquitoes I mean we even went
that far we always were looking to make
a dollar every [ __ ] day we did
something did it go down for you because
when I was younger I did that but then
when I got like a job in like 15 14 I
get there it was hard for me to ask for
money as an adult like it's we're not
asking we're taking you just take it
there was a soccer field when I was
growing up shits in Park a German
[ __ ] Hall and they had people who you
could see eight down a thousand people
in the soccer field and it was covered
by sheet metal we figured out that every
sheet of sheet metal we get a hundred
and forty dollars you don't know how
many nights we're on top of that roof
taking a piece of sheet metal off
hammering it down the woods and walking
it to the [ __ ] sheet metal yard and
getting 140 hours and splitting it three
ways and then taking two sheets down
taking three sheets and you people at
home were listening on Jesus Christ sure
did you guys ever stop no no I still
love being a car salesman making ten
thousand a month and at lunchtime I
would walk into the boulder mall and
steal cross pens when it wasn't payday I
would ask the lady can I see those pens
and she would open up the thing and walk
away and I would take a handful of cross
pens and it sounds the sounds in for
twenty dollars a piece
it never ended like that that mentality
never at like I was always
wheeling and dealing you had to there's
record clubs those Columbia house BMG
13c albums for a penny so so we did all
these do
for names they'd come to our address you
know you don't put a social security
number so they never messed up your
credit and then we'd go to this place
called the English town auction on
Saturday and Sunday just get a table we
wouldn't pay for the tape all you're
supposed to pay like 50 bucks to rent
the table or 30 whatever it was and we
just sit there all the album's that we
got and we'd sell them so we paid a
penny we just paid pay you just take the
penny some tenant and every 100 I'll get
13 hours from Annie and then you had to
buy him later on and then you just blew
it off you didn't buy him they would
send another [ __ ] yeah they'd send a new
you to record was the record of Mon
thing okay good I got this now and they
go we need 1386 from you just blow it
off
burn that burn those bills or just if a
friend got a new apartment we just get
that adore what's your new address and
then we just forward all those bills
there and he'd get like 40 bills a day
and we just saw him at the English an
auction for like five bucks and we walk
away with $70 [ __ ] Columbia House they
were in Terre Haute Indiana yeah Tara
yeah in the end I knew them that add
just by heart and you know I would just
take my magazines and I would fill out
Columbia house mailing for the house
across the street
mmm and you'd wait for [ __ ] in the
mailman they see the big box come yeah
the big box you well up the stairs and
take the box and then you'd have
duplicate out and all the albums were
false anyway they were all duplicates
yeah they weren't they they weren't
great they were really thin yeah let's
make copies that's why you got 13 of
them for a penny and then you had to
agree to buy four of them over the next
three years yeah for like twenty eight
nine yeah which is ridiculous is
ridiculous that's how they made their
money back whenever they change formats
from album to cassette to CD
I'll go go okay I need all the Black
Sabbath stuff now in a cassette now I
need it in a CD and I'll just get it
through Columbia House I'm like [ __ ] it
I already paid for it once I'm not
paying for it again I actually wrote
actually wrote a check to Columbia House
back in like 2004 when I started making
money in comedy and I sent him a check
for two grand I said just cash it I I
you know ripped you guys off four years
or whatever just cash it because I felt
bad huh yeah I never I'd yet I cashed it
they have a mail you think you know did
nothing I didn't hear back from
foreclose [ __ ] but I don't care I
made me feel guilty I almost wrote him a
check but if they're not gonna say thank
know they didn't say thank you leave me
I ripped them off for probably five
grand
oh I got him - I there was another
company called Fingerhut where they'd
have like these little CD players or
whatever o'clock radios all these little
gadgets and it was the same thing you
know you could get it for free and then
you just have to buy stuff so me and my
brother around Christmastime we get
presents for our family like a CD player
and [ __ ] like that we just fit and we
just blow them off and never acknowledge
them again they'd be chasing or sit down
they had these great catalogs a little
like [ __ ] it was almost like sharp
orange image right but sheer do your
stuff okay Michael Chitti a version of
sharp then you shoot with no money no
money they'd send you one thing with no
money and then you had to buy like four
other things are you [ __ ] kidding me
it's amazing how long didn't Columbia
House last yeah they're still based
around but it years I mean I'm like how
does this company stay in business cuz I
don't know anyone that paid them I don't
know one person they never paid him I
tried to do what my brother was ripping
them off so much I go you know what I
should really just do it I'm making a
little money now I'm gonna put it in my
real name and they turned me down I'm
like you [ __ ] said I just put
in a Dan Marino's name so I was a damn
Moreno fan I got 13 [ __ ] Metallica
records the next day how crazy is that
I'm like really at my own name and
you're gonna tear me down
I started [ __ ] with Columbia House
and I was in Catholic school somebody
told me it just send it in I was okay
you see yeah I started I think I got
like American Pie right Bob McClane yeah
yeah it was one of the first times I got
super fly I got from Columbia I got all
those albums from Columbia House the
first time then they'd sing your letters
and I just throw them away then I
figured homage let me send an account of
my mother and they took it I sent one to
my stepfather and then I just started
putting fake add fake names and sending
it to my address they would still send
them same what you could use the address
like 15 times with 15 different names
you just make up a name and they would
keep sending on the people across the
street with tristana's right they had
two girls family things I said today
right
I said boy lows to the house because we
used to get super eights when super
rating no and I told that bit for years
about people to know that before YouTube
where you are but pornhub and all that
[ __ ]
if you wanted to get porn you had to
order it
male when I was like 10 11 you had to
get porno in the mail so you had it and
they didn't even go to like it wasn't
even playboy or hustler it was like
regular magazines you'd go to the back
of it had three-point O's for 1995 and
if you order now you're gonna project it
so they would send you this little mini
super a projector it was called
reel-to-reel something yeah then you had
to put it in and you had to put a sheet
up and the pornos were just god-awful
like the reason why I don't watch porn
today is because of those pornos from
the 70s whatever they sent in the mail
what do all those women are dead like
all those women got killed they did not
survive they were lied to
they picked him up in a van you could
see like they were crack hoes even
before it was crying like it was that
bad the pornos you can get pornos no man
I don't remember dad it I don't remember
that I would have definitely have done
that I don't me and my friends did it I
think one time right all it took yeah it
scared the [ __ ] out of us like we we
went into an area that you weren't
supposed to going yeah it was me
Sabatino de specially our brothers and I
think one of the boughs a nose and we
all chipped in five bucks because it was
like $19.99 plus shipping and handling
and you gotta wait six weeks for them to
process it was just like getting a
ticket in the 70s I give you wanted to
go see the who like who are you in 76 we
had a send Pink Floyd also Pink Floyd
the wall will not Pink Floyd the wall
I'm sorry there was somebody else that
PLJ in the old day he had a mail or
[ __ ] a check or money order in the
PLJ and then they would send you tickets
back they would send you a weather with
four tickets you only were allowed to
get four tickets you didn't know that
check yeah no I did remember yeah you
couldn't get too many they wanted to
give him the scalpers they don't want
this guy for science for Texas so let's
say Judas Priest was doing five nights
at the Palladium you would order Lee
would order I would order kiss you in
order five so five of us would order
five take four tickets and if you went
then we
go Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and
usually if you mail then you got him
yeah unless you meld it in two weeks
late you didn't get [ __ ]
okay but if you mailed it right PLJ said
tomorrow at 8 a.m. if you meld it that
day you usually got tickets especially
at the guard yes did that
yes came every September five or six
nights you had a mail [ __ ] in to get it
back but porno when I first was the
first time I saw porno was born on that
you had an order in the mail and I still
remember wait the six weeks for it and
[ __ ] getting it being like a secret
[ __ ] party like handshakes and people
came over we had it we had to do it in
my house up in the attic and it was odd
we had to bring a fan in that condition
yeah like that's how crazy that [ __ ] was
yeah man I think I lit those balloons on
fire we melted
that's how gusting they were they were
that [ __ ] disgusting it's just like
we thought we're gonna see like models
this [ __ ] uh-uh it looked like woman
that had been run over and they slowed
them down
the hotel is nice [ __ ] it was bad it was
really [ __ ] bad damn yeah cuz I mean
you just basically had a magazine what
we do with the Columbia house stuff if
we you know got it shipped to our dress
there was I remember there's one kid in
the neighborhood we all hated he was a
dick so we just forward over to his
address
cuz you would you get the bill and you'd
forward a change of address and just put
his address so now all the bills would
go to his house and he didn't know who
was coming from because I put Dan Marino
down so he had no idea wasn't my name so
he had no idea what his [ __ ] was coming
and just get stacks of bills fuck'em
when I was home this time - I remembered
something you know I remembered he used
to bring the coke up to Dan Marino at
the University of Pittsburgh I knew
those guys oh yeah yeah I'm telling you
that's why he dropped all the way to
Dolphin said pick 24 that year because
there was always rumors that he was
doing coke in college cuz he was gonna
be like number one in five quarterbacks
went before him before Kenny O'Brien all
these guys cuz it of coke rumors in the
da field we'll take a chance on him what
he's done in Miami way I didn't know you
were that much with them Oh huge yeah
huge
dolphin fan of marina
and I wound up being get to know him
because I worked on inside the NFL like
in 2004 and he was on there and [ __ ] so
we became friends and stuff I still see
him from time to time
he's great dude that guy after like
inside the NFL Bob Costas Chris
Collinsworth Chris Carr taro did like a
party or something like that afterwards
they'd all go sit at the table like you
know the hosts and stuff like that with
all the executives from HBO Marina would
hang with the friggin camera guys and
drink beers with them and just tell
stories he wanted to hang with the
blue-collar guys he was always like that
could grow up from Pittsburgh he's a
Pittsburgh guy yeah that's for a guy
yeah I'm gonna forget what Pittsburgh
played West Virginia Marino scene a year
and there was a guy on West Virginia
called Darryl Talley oh yeah he went to
the bills playing yeah he's an item on
it yeah you should have seen him in
college really like in college it was
like who is this [ __ ] guy he was
doing everything he had to face pain and
number 56 thousand people saken's people
biting people [ __ ] into septum balls
I was like who the [ __ ] is this guy
stole my marina that was on a couple
weeks ago the quarterback thing 34:30
well yeah we're that way i Marino yeah
damn [ __ ] brilliant what the Yankees
did without where how I just did not
want to play for the [ __ ] cults he's
like I'm not doing it
yeah not [ __ ] doing it yet I was
amazing you know and yeah he had a great
senior junior Nemorino Phil didn't have
a great senior year and there was drug
rumors about him and he dropped all the
way and Miami picked them up I still
have the kids telling me they were gonna
pit the party not saying his name like
he was the big deal in the time but I
still remember a handful of kids a girl
specifically that she was dating one of
those guys I was coming outs in county
picking up the [ __ ] in North Bergen and
bringing it right up the pit for the
weekends because the kid went to st.
Joe's on West New York right there was a
kid from the st. Joe's Western here that
went to Pitt and he played it all four
years of Marino he was the [ __ ]
source of that of that [ __ ] powder
poor marina and he was still on powder
in the NFL to suppose
yeah I mean if he lived in Miami and
stuff you know he never got caught or
anything I don't know I don't know
the receivers did a duper and Clayton
yeah all those guys like it was the
fourth oh yeah yeah they got they got
busted and even later on life like duper
was dealing and stuff like that all
those Miami guys there was always these
former dolphins mercury Morris was
originally original one got caught with
coke back in the 70s it was in jail for
like five years
yeah dealing I don't know I don't know
your history Jim I don't know if you did
coke or anything like that but I always
think about like could you be a musician
on tour or like an athlete who's playing
games and have like it seems like it
would take too much out of you to have a
problem like that but still be able to
go out there and perform at like that
crazy level no those guys in the 70s of
a bunch of baseball players like ten
baseball player star has got busted for
doing coke victorious yeah and the Keith
Hernandez was involved and they
partnered with Ronda Larry Candelaria
Candelaria Candyman Lords taalib and
[ __ ] I saw Laurence tail in a strip club
it's say it was Saturday night at like
2:00 a.m. and he had a game Sunday at
1:00 p.m.
in Jersey he was [ __ ] hanging out
with strippers [ __ ] guzzling drinks
back and he had a game in what 11 hours
they're just that good I guess they're
just that good they could perform under
that type of I guess so you know I did
it three years I didn't get high and go
on stage but but you've talked about how
long have you got high too high like
sometimes your sense wouldn't be as oh
no you have no contact you have no
emotion on your material it's just words
on a paper all those guys that got
[ __ ] up and I work with a lot of them
when I first started if they ever had a
second show on a weekend they were
terrible the first show they were pretty
good because they were just in a groove
and a nice buzz on by the second show
you have to wait an hour between a
second show slumbereth on they went back
on they were terrible terrible yeah yeah
it just doesn't work
yeah you can't be that [ __ ] up for
like seven hours you know you start the
first show starts at a you're not you
get offstage at 12:30 or whatever five
and a half hours
it just doesn't work and there's too
much downtime in between Lily get more
[ __ ] up the more [ __ ] up and then
that you know maybe doing some coke to
get back up and they're drinking a ton
and all that it's just never and I
always saw that going like I'm not gonna
do it I'm never gonna do that I mean I
never did coke anyway but I'm never
gonna be [ __ ] up cuz I could see how
much it affects the show I got into
comedy in June of 91 and then st.
Patty's Day at 92
I bought some coke like I'm gonna do
some coke before I go on stage I'm not
Richard Pryor did it
I told he did it go on stage and it was
such a disaster and never again I would
do it right from the stage to the
bathroom but I would never go up on
stage never and it would make I saw the
difference in made when I got hired a
night before went on stage the next day
I would go on stage for four nights and
just bomb because I was getting high the
night before then I can feel it then
when I had a big show I wouldn't get
high for like a day before it so I'd be
clean for like 24 4 you know who's a
badass serious show but I always got
high after a show that's why there we
got no well it wasn't like yeah I really
[ __ ] you it really affects you if you
get [ __ ] up the night before and you
got shows the next day then if he sleeps
off and everything like that you're
exhausted on stage you're just not
thinking straight
you hear about Jon Jones talking about
he was doing coke all before those DC
fights I guess they're just so like
they're just machines like well you have
that muscle memory you know I heard
Lawrence Taylor was snoring it bothered
me what people would say well the reason
where Lawrence Taylor so good is because
he snorts coke that's [ __ ] that's
completely [ __ ]
because I'm gonna being locked up and we
would do speed on Mondays and Monday
nights we would all be allowed to go to
a grammar school like a mile away from
the [ __ ] prison and play basketball
and I would be a mess
I would be a [ __ ] mess that was speed
I can't imagine doing like coke I my
heart would be everywhere my breathing
would be off my timing
would be all and I was a young kid and I
just felt a denim like that I don't
think this works if you get high and do
what you're supposed to do listen I'm
sure that there's a thousand comics that
have done coke them gone on stage and
done great it just didn't work for me
cuz then you get in the habit or you
have to do it all the time you feel like
it's all superstition so man I kill with
it's not gonna do it every night you're
doing five six nights a week you're
gonna be [ __ ] dead in ten years yeah
people always give me [ __ ] like you
don't drink I go I go I do it it's five
six nights a week I've been doing it for
28 29 years
like I had no liver left if I'm I need
to have beers before I go onstage yeah
every night you know what I mean like
I'm I would never get in then that habit
of doing that and then I got a drive if
I'm like [ __ ] that I'm you know that's
not the most I can't keep it together if
I drink and drive I cannot keep it
together I'm not a big drinker but if I
have a half a beer and I get in the car
my heart rates [ __ ] pumping and I got
cuz I have no credibility
once you have alcohol on your breath and
you get pulled over by a cop you have
zero credibility even if it's even if
you just had a little bit of beer with
your meal you have no credibility you
have nowhere to come from cuz once he
asks you've you've been drinking you
gotta say yes and you gotta take that
[ __ ] test so I'd rather not drink and
do 90 and take a chance you know many
times the cops pulled me over and our
speed no witness but weren't you in a
car on me and I just got pulled over for
doing 80 and then we didn't get it thick
Oxnard I said yeah cuz I'm a jet I'm a
gentleman a and B I don't have alcohol
on my breath I could prove your point a
lot more when you don't have alcohol and
your car don't smell like reefer and I
knew this thirty years ago like when I
would read that somebody got pulled over
and they had a roach in the car and had
three kilos of coke if I was a judge I
give additional time yeah totally stupid
like I would have that charge felonies
stupid like I would have that charge if
I have anything in my car if I have more
than two joints in my car I don't do
over the speed limit they gave us a
right in California they gave us the
right to smoke pot whatever we wanted to
do you really need to smoke pot in your
car now if you do you're a [ __ ] idiot
right yeah you're a [ __ ] idiot you
know do you really need to smoke pot in
your car
not really California gave you a [ __ ]
chance to smoke all the pot you want in
your [ __ ] house or on your balcony
you don't need to smoke in the colony
lose your license you're gonna crash
they're gonna trace it to that you're
gonna get [ __ ] sued and the whole you
know and I forgot I bet you kill someone
so yeah he's walking across the street
you don't see him whether even if you
were sober and he did in your high
forget it you're going to jail minimum
of ten years yeah Donte Stallworth a
couple of years ago yeah he just hit
some guy was walking across the flats
that's like my nightmare pay a [ __ ]
attention to life if you pay attention
you'll save you eliminate twenty percent
of the bad [ __ ] that can happen what's
paying attention me who gives a [ __ ]
who's calling you right when you're in a
[ __ ] car and I'm driving and somebody
calls you it tells me who's calling me I
don't need to pick it up I don't need to
text when I'm driving I don't want to
text when I'm [ __ ] driving I don't
want to text at all so that's why I
don't pay attention to it if you pay
attention to life you won't have those
problems even when I was in my deepest
drug culpers I always pay it attention I
can't tell you how many times I tell my
daughter to pay attention and she does
no she walks with a head up ya know your
surrounding though your [ __ ]
surroundings I always ask who's in the
room like yeah damn I said to look
behind you you know and I T see when you
[ __ ] walked up to me you should have
made sure that guy was there you didn't
because you didn't look you got to look
around you got to keep your eyes open at
all times when I see stupid [ __ ] on the
news it breaks my heart especially as a
parent at the park well hang on the park
I see parents [ __ ] turn their backs
and [ __ ] you don't never turn your back
on you can't your eyes are always on
your kid if somebody talks to you and
they're over here and it forces you I
stopped the conversation I stopped the
[ __ ] conversation I want to watch
what the [ __ ] is going on as of all
times at all [ __ ] times yeah I
a little off a road where the speed
limits like 35 miles an hour I'm like a
corner house and my son and his friends
are always playing in my yard to playing
baseball whatever and I always tell him
that's listen if that ball ever goes and
then I rode under no circumstances go
get it I go I got 17 more balls in the
house don't ever think you can go get
that ball real quick and then run off
you're not so then this no I go don't
ever go over this fence you don't I mean
so they I just put in it I tell them
every time they play I go you guys know
what the rule is if that ball goes over
there yeah we don't go get it exactly
even if it's the last one left so you
just got to let them know man don't ever
on that you know I can make it notice
you know so they know it's fully used to
English English town auction I live near
there still I bring my son there this
there's so much stolen [ __ ] there every
week everything is great this [ __ ] at
that English town flea market but the
mini what is it the mini car English
town they got the raceway par with the
funny cars yet still there - trying to
outlaw because it allowed noises in the
summer I love it I said on my deck I
hear dos Reis those drag racing cars I'm
like this is cool they still have on us
but I used to go to that thing in
nineteen like 76 and we used to sell
sneakers yeah
converse limousines for the feet he
everything down there was stolen
everything cost because everything just
fell off the [ __ ] truck it was just
an outlet to sell stolen stuff watches
you go down and look at somebody and
give them like a look
mmm like a wink and they'll take you for
a walk like is this all you have just
look at you for a couple of minutes and
you look at them they look a year
they're like let's take a walk and you
go to their car and they got tons of
[ __ ] that car grenades [ __ ] dead
bodies in this town New Jersey was this
[ __ ] was unbelievable I used to buy you
sneakers there for like 10 bucks like
used high-tops
so I cigarettes carton cigarettes and
then fireworks like m-80s blockbusters a
guy in a coal would have a table out
like you'd have a cover over and you
walk by like I got fireworks like you
wouldn't couldn't keep my on the open
mats of firecrackers and you'd buy [ __ ]
right there
like you know quarter stick a dynamite
for like six bucks a blockbuster was a
quarter stick of dynamite and we just
blow people's mailboxes up in the
neighborhood we didn't like we just said
it and then there'd just be a stick
there and you wouldn't even know where
the mailbox went so dynamite Tilly thank
you yeah 1414 we don't give a [ __ ] we
would tip me my friends would take the
train into the city and go into
Chinatown and go to I don't know it's
some shady apartment and we'd be stealin
the fireworks at the same time we
distract a woman that's gonna sell so
we'd be shoving him down our pants
Blockbuster and come back with all these
fireworks and just go go go sell them
than a neighborhood everybody else
because there was a car there was a guy
that came off from Chinatown close to a
fourth of July that would sell fireworks
out of his car in the summertime right
before the fourth of July then we got
hit we found out that you could undercut
that [ __ ] just by going to
Chinatown yourself yeah we were kids
eighth grade seventh grade we would go
to Chinatown and buy those things we buy
a gross of bottled water across I did a
1444 bottles forty-four bottle rock it's
a gross and [ __ ] we buy we light up the
whole math we get the mats
yeah mattify or except we got how many
firecrackers we're an aerobatic [ __ ]
idea it's amazing you're still like 150
packs a fire and have all your fingers
and oh my god I'm a better cop to come
around a week before the fourth of July
and show you pictures of people's hands
that have been blown off yeah working on
me we tell they go [ __ ] yeah like who
cares I'm still scared if I work we said
to have firecracker fights like we do
like fire I'm throwing money I throw
them at each other oh my god let me take
the stick off the fire you take the
stick off of Bottlerocket yeah I don't
find it's a [ __ ] chaser
because it would just round it goes
right so they would call them [ __ ]
chase and even the Chinese people go you
bite [ __ ] chaser
look at them like what the [ __ ] you
talking about the black people call it
don't they wouldn't they never mess a
fire one could bring those things with
some black people don't mess around with
fireworks or cryotherapy
you'll never see a brother in a crowd
there appeal ugh Oh [ __ ] hilarious
that what they and it got correct
the thing about Chinatown is that every
time and I'm talking about the one in
New York
I don't know what about San Francisco or
in LA and I'm talking about that the mid
70s that every they be like little
dealers on the corner and again they
would sell you the you know firework
firecrackers bottle rockets smoke bombs
mal Easons cherry bombs was the general
yeah - cherry bombs making amazing right
there was a for ya yeah for for cherry
bombs make a man and matey and foreign
matey's is a quarter stick of dynamite
good to know so we'd [ __ ] my 20ma T's
and [ __ ] I mean the things we did
with those ideas we blew holes in walls
just tied them together and there was
always one kid who knew how to [ __ ]
put everything together he was missing a
finger yeah there was a kid on 148th
Street that for like $10 he would hold
on the [ __ ] and let it blow but he's
hilarious he was missing fingernails
he'd got this fingernail blown off one
year from a farm
was that your was that your $10 not
really I just couldn't believe that he
would hold fireworks he was like a
Vietnam vet ursa and he would let things
blow up with his hands cherry bombs
m-80s and you had something stronger
than him at the blockbuster the
blockbuster blockbuster was actually a
quarter stick of dynamite and then you
had duh what's the thing that shot the
balls that you shot people with rocket
launcher like a little rocket they call
them something Oh lick the top and balls
came up okay Maya boss Roman can open
can roman candle roman candles read way
on fire with a robust yeah every year we
get a rolling like we hated you if you
didn't tip I'll give money I'll give
teeth the kids good we would burn your
roof with all the [ __ ] candles you
know big [ __ ] rooms we burn a jobs
court given that Terrace in 30 a tree
because we would stop with the roman
candles till we leave your roof on fire
listen to you guys makes me not want to
have kid like this scares all this is
what it is to be a kid yeah we shot some
bottle rockets into a field then it
would start on fire fire fire yeah they
had to call the fire department put it
out because it was it was in August or
July it was hot and it just lit right up
that's what fuels do oh my goood make
gasoline bombs like Molotov cocktails
some cocktails and just leave us three
gunpowder to light on fire so I can go
down the block I mean it was [ __ ]
nuts it was not we love we blow up this
guy's mailboxes kid we didn't like what
a blockbuster quarter stick of dynamite
my sister was babysitting six blocks
away and heard it she's like I went to
the Y heard that I went to the window I
got out we blow up his mailbox you'd
still be in jail today for some of this
stuff I think they don't know like I
don't think I've until I moved to LA I
didn't see fireworks or here like it was
only like towns had firework shows cuz
they were they were illegal in
Massachusetts don't be a little firework
on the street and the most I saw was
sparklers should I did when I was four
exactly you just why the sparklers stand
there like a photo booth cake and wait
for it to sizzle yeah we yeah when they
sold that in a story like I that's lame
yeah no I'm sure some people had like
then went to Pennsylvania or West
Virginia or something but there was
nothing that I know of Jews don't buy
fireworks what a [ __ ] and we used to
go to south or a border we go to Florida
every year with the family vacation is
in the station I don't I don't know it's
gotta look like it's 1920 cuz when I was
a kid it looked like you [ __ ] see if
south of never all the signs in North
Carolina I think it's out I think it's
the water in North Carolina if you drove
from New York City to Miami lose the
middle it was the middle like 12 hour
drive stop there the rules of shitty so
we'd stack up on all the fireworks there
was shitty but they'd sell yeah and they
had every sign every like 50 miles see
that they they definitely have a
established nineteen
9 let me see where it is I think they
have it cuz they have a website
was it a vacation spot or was it just a
truck spot but there was a big truck
stop big truck stop you know that was
pretty much and you go there you would
eat and the main thing was the fireworks
yes
South Carolina that's it yeah interstate
95 that makes sense it was right off the
highway going down tomorrow we just
drive down there they go your fireworks
and drive back now cuz we could always
get him in New York so we didn't have to
but if we want a family vacation we
would stop there and then we'd pick up a
bunch of stuff there's a big gorilla up
front you guys Sapa the [ __ ] board I
forgot all about that chase do those
drives all the time when I was a kid
New York City to Miami and back with my
uncles my mom yeah and we always stop at
[ __ ] south of the border nothin the
food I got sick that like that's why I'm
gonna miss out to the border because the
food was just [ __ ] god-awful
they had like generic hamburgers and
they have six restaurants it says yeah
no not bueno or it wasn't back the
headline just got carsick or whatever
this is a time of the year like I'm
mentally short 30 years probably like I
have last time I was a seaside park had
to be like 98 people and I didn't know
the water have not been on the Jersey
Shore no eyes right Park or any of that
stuff when you go nothing since the
eighties I was telling you before the
show I went to convention hall last
Sunday to see like a wrestling match it
took my kid there and his friend
nothing's changed same chandeliers same
everything right on the boardwalk in
Asbury Park
I thought they cleaned all that up well
they left that but they did but that in
in that little endure a little mall what
a convention hall is it's still the same
you know they got all the shops and
they're more of modern shops but they
never change anything cuz it was
historic that I'd stay with the Stone
Pony they haven't changed anything the
storm land up lure clue was cleaned up
well people are moving to Newark now
because they can't because
Hoboken's full you know we Hawkins full
Jersey cities full right now sort of
truck so people of Newark is now people
that want to live in New York that can't
afford it all these young people are
moving now to her down son with all the
new urns of the metal with that's the
new tale record view is it a malleable
views of the George Washington Bridge
because there's no left yeah so now you
have a view of the Meadowlands that's
the new thing when they sell a house now
what are you crazy you got a view of the
Meadowlands it's beautiful out there
what the [ __ ] wants to see that [ __ ]
yeah I never understood that and when I
was shooting this movie they said that
they shot scenes in Newark and they go
it's not good that even at night this is
dog Larry and it was kind of crazy
yeah it's still bad I mean like we're
back yeah I know that oh I was excited
to go to Lourdes
well they got where the Devils play it
that uh right the Prudential Center
right I should know and they have Nazis
there yeah when you get off the train in
Newark off of New Jersey Transit they
have like a Skyway where you'd never
have to hit the streets of Newark to get
to the Prudential Center they did that
for the scared white people like all
right listen we'll go to Newark because
we know we don't have to walk on the
street to go if we take the train it was
that bad or still that it's still around
that area I just did a gig around there
about a year ago it's bad alright but
you know they have a lot of cops in that
area so they make sure because one white
person you know gets killed there no
one's ever gonna go there again so they
know they block off the streets they
make sure it's safe for people coming in
out of those events there to have a
bunch of shows there now too so if
people don't want to go to garden or
anything like that but yeah so but just
starting to build it up because there's
no more room in New Jersey and people I
can't afford New York City Queens is
full Brooklyn full all that stuff it's
too expensive so they're actually coming
to Newark now which is crazy everything
is [ __ ] full three weeks I was there
I've never seen so many people in my
[ __ ] life yeah
they got people on top of people they
got people that whole river road down
there but you see all that [ __ ] that's
there I mean I used to live in you know
Cliffside Park and the Briarcliff that
big building that was built in 1972 it I
was like the only high-rise in that area
that in a galaxy
was in West New York those are the only
buildings and stuff and it's like I
didn't go back to have like 10 years I
went down I'm like holy [ __ ]
it's like 27 holes for rent for like a
one-bedroom like on the water there and
people also Edgewater's the Giants and
the Knicks and I saw glory by nature
when I was down there to sing a track I
saw him down there right you have see
Jim you got that money yeah the money to
live on that [ __ ] thing down almost
they used to be rat-infested when I was
a [ __ ] kid elicits from what he said
rat-infested yeah gross yeah I mean it's
just overlap me and Norton me and Jim
Norton wanted to move close to New York
City and we got a place in Cliffside
Park we're paying $800 it was a
two-bedroom for 800 bucks and I had my
girlfriend at the time living there so
we're splitting rent three ways $800 a
month it was [ __ ] great as a [ __ ]
but it was writing Cliffside Park it was
five minutes from the Lincoln Tunnel ten
minutes from the George Washington
Bridge was perfect that we just said
John Claire be there locally st. Barts
yeah it was great
I love how quick you could be another I
used to walk from Cliffside to the
bridge I can't believe what they did
around the bridge they should be a spot
like a block from the George Washington
Bridge whether it was a red light like
that one above you in front of it and if
that light was beeping that means fresh
bagels are coming out of the oven
okay people would just [ __ ] pull over
and go on and get a dozen fresh bagels
out of the oven the red light would just
be blinking I went up there there's no
more red light that's still there's the
tower that diner the Fort Lee dine oh
yeah yeah that's it I don't never go
everything else is brand new and Korean
yeah and Korean yeah yeah if you don't
hablo English damn you don't speak
Chinese or Korean you are done in Fort
Lee really it's all Korean they took
over Fort Lee POW Park and rich real
Park you're gonna have to try some
kimchi now no let's oh no no no but it's
everywhere tall Korean that the Fort Lee
saloon is gone
babe's taxi that we right under the
bridge is God
is gone all those days are long gone the
hip club up there was the Fort Lee
saloon it was right on the side of
George Washington Bridge I asked my
brother's it's still there
God truffles gone all those bars long
they're gone it's a complete different
[ __ ] world and it's an expensive
[ __ ] world to to live up there I used
to think I wanted to live in New York
you do yeah I it seems like it'd be for
all the shitty parts like the random to
many people it seems like like there's
no other place I'm 56 years old guys
called you 54 you know what man
New York does nothing for me now really
yeah because I'm 54 years old I can't
take advantage of what it's got to offer
I can't take advantage of what it's got
to offer New York is a late City and not
really not anymore
not what I saw you know New York well
that was growing up was a late City like
when Ari told me he was moving to New
York
I said go because you're not gonna make
it happen here the way you live in New
York and he loves it well Mitch Hedberg
told me he was thinking about I go go
because if you're gonna attack a certain
if you can't sleep New York is for you
yeah if you don't like going to bed at
1:00 and you like being out at 1:00 you
know when I was shooting this we were
incorrigible Brooklyn there's a
Ridgewood Brooklyn Ridgewood Clinic
Queens Ridgewood Mercer okay this is a
true story
we were our call time was sick sometimes
so you have to break six hours after
your call time by law for lunch
sometimes the night it was said one
night it was seven o'clock with my call
time and that one o'clock we had lunch
and we had a drive from the set to the
place we'll read like a downstairs of a
church and it was maybe guys six block
drive on Myrtle Street in Brooklyn and
I'm telling you this with [ __ ] all
the sincerity in the world there was
more businesses open at 1:00 in the
morning
along that route then there are and all
of [ __ ] this area where we oh yeah
there was more restaurants open on that
strip there was a vapor store when it
was open and they had twenty
[ __ ] in there smoking [ __ ]
babies I'm the [ __ ] when we got to the
place where we're eating that was the
Punisher and I looked at him and I go
hey man did you notice that on the drive
here or that [ __ ] shitty Street there
was more businesses in a ten-mile Drive
open more places to eat hummus sushi
[ __ ] us a cheesesteak place bodegas
up the ass
the how loud cafe was open all these
things were open more than he and he
goes imagine living up and [ __ ] what
was he living at Ventura County what's
Alki what's name oh oh hi oh hi he was
imagine living in Ojai
there ain't dick to eat after seven
o'clock there was more businesses open
on Myrtle Avenue in a five minute drive
then there was all of this at nine
o'clock like if I say me at nine o'clock
you're hungry what do we got we got that
shitty pizza Tony's pizza and you got
Denny's and you got all these shitty
taco stands that you don't know what you
eat yeah then with all the [ __ ] horse
just to Santa Anita no these places with
all these horses that are dying in Santa
Nina what what are we up to thirty is
year and it's [ __ ] June it's not even
June and dirty horses have died that
meats gotta go somewhere so if you're
eating some food trucks in the LA area
I wouldn't [ __ ] advise it so my point
is that it's a late-night City right you
know I have no use of being out at 1:00
in the morning
I don't want if you got a spot for me at
11:30 I'm not gonna do it yeah I'm some
of them going the you know the Comedy
Cellar I remember doing it over the
summer like 145 yes fine I'm like I
can't do this it's just too late for me
yeah it's too I'm past I used it all
time I spot one 10 a.m. No
- do - no problem used to do it - so I
have no use for New York I Love New York
don't get me wrong what I'm saying to
you but I have no use for New York I'm
not gonna get in the [ __ ] train and
go do six spots on one night that that
ship sailed you know I don't have the
you know if if I have a spot in the city
and I got to leave Edgewater and jump on
a ferry and come over that's gonna be a
deep spot well you better think twice
before you do so I have no use for New
York in that way I have to be honest to
myself yeah but me being 30 a young
comic I don't like to sleep anyway like
I'm not gonna go to bed till 4:00 anyway
like Ari I could call Ari at one here
he picks up like nothing hey what's up
nothing what are you doing I'm just
saying it
yeah you don't have any times I'm coming
up on Laurel Canyon 11:30 I'll call Ari
and the answer the phone like not nap
it's 2:30 in the morning yeah I like
that's loose yeah I don't have that use
anymore I don't I'm not gonna stay out
too would know cuz yeah remember coming
living right outside New York my hours I
go to bed at 3:00 and get up around
10:00 or 11:00 so I could stay out it
didn't matter but then you know as you
get older and then you have a kid I'm
like [ __ ] that I'm you know I'm not
doing a midnight show I'll do the 8:00
and 10:30 show at the stand or whatever
like that and then I'm done I'm not
running around doing seven different
shows I don't give a [ __ ] I'm just gonna
stay in one spot I'm not Robin finally
yeah I'm never on a subway going here
and getting here and run on stage it's
like yeah I'm good I just need a couple
sets even the store I do the 9:15 on
Saturday night 9:50 no I won't do it I
don't want to be at 11 o'clock and I got
no use out there 10:30 maybe the way
this Tuesday 10:30 on Thursday that's it
I can't even imagine being out at
midnight anymore
it just changes it because I mean I've
always loved that I was in the second
show at the bull Gotham not till 11
o'clock show yeah it's unethical
Oh Dan yeah that would be nice not gonna
happen that means I don't get out of
there - water - I don't go to bed till
three and I'm on the first flight out
it's not worth it to me so she's so wait
out it gets to the point and it's not
even being old it's just you just don't
see the use for it anymore don't have
any useful I wish I did I wish I could
stay after warrant I can't [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah there's some people that that
that fits your lifestyle it fit my
lifestyle thirty years ago doesn't fit
it today you know what I was doing three
four sets a night at thirty years old or
whatever I was doing like the same
material I wasn't really working on it
it wasn't special to me I'm just like
okay it's another set as you get older
you'll do less sets but it's more
important to you okay I need to work on
these bits I got to go out on a road I
got to come out with new material so
it's you really it wasn't doing just
because I was doing more sets I wasn't
advance in my career at all as you get
old and that you realize I got I got a
I've really gotta focus on these bits
there's too many distractions when I was
thirty I'm just trying to get [ __ ] you
know what I mean after shows old that's
the only reason I was doing it and I
just show the sets almost gotten away
well with anything you learn how to work
smarter yeah with anything in your life
eventually you do it so long you're wait
a second I have to learn how to work
this smart you know it's like I used to
sit at a coffee shop for three hours and
I set that coffee shop for an hour and
15 minutes and I get done what I would
have done three hours in the old days
now I could do it I get up break for an
hour and then come back you learn that
if you sit there for three hours after
an hour and the happy they aren't doing
anything anyway
you're gonna make phone calls you gotta
look at something else you know look at
this on the computer [ __ ] it so now I
rather sit there for an hour 15 give it
an hour 15 and then I go to crowd
therapy and break it up go to the weed
store then I go back to writing and I
get more you learned from was it we
saying that you work smarter work
smarter yeah that's it when I was young
too I'd do 20 two sets a week you know
yeah that was necessary at the time but
I could have done the same damage by
doing 16 cents
five little sets I didn't necessarily
have to do but as a young comic you
can't turn down anything no you're in no
position to turn down anything as a
young comic your first 15-20 years you
can turn down dick you know you're
coming off a plane they got a spot for
you do it now I got a family I have age
I have a lot of things that have to give
my time too
it's hard it's hard when you have a
child you know your child full-time
pretty much yeah three days a week you
have to give them all the attention they
could you know people get mad at me oh
you don't get high online no more you
know I can't get hired late in the
morning no more cuz I got 22 things to
do at 9:30 and I can't walk into these
places with my eyes red I walked into
daycare once that floor they told my
wife he stunk like [ __ ] weed I can't
[ __ ] walking through it the school
smell like that weed I got I got a deal
with parents and whatnot so your
priorities change so you learn how to
work smarter and at the end that was
somebody told me this when I was
starting that it's working smart it's
working all day but working smart I get
more done in eight hours than most
people do in a week I could do more than
eight hours I have everything written
down
I just spew it out I'm done for the week
I love living like that yeah and
everything I have to my Wednesday and
the rest of all we got gonna do but
maybe work out I got the same thing like
Mike son goes to school gets on the bus
at 8:00 he gets home at 3:00 off the bus
it's right in front of my house I know
from 8:00 till 3:00 I got to get all my
I got everything done so when he gets
off that bus at 3:00 it's all bull just
hat we're hanging whatever he wants to
do wherever he wants to go whatever so I
just no get all that [ __ ] done I got
that window don't [ __ ] it up and yeah by
Wednesday I'm done with all my [ __ ] I
got my kid Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday I'm
doing gigs where I take the time off or
do whatever and I get all my [ __ ] yeah
and I was never I never had discipline
like that if you were never good in
school with discipline I'm sure you
weren't either you just got by you're
like whatever I cheated on whatever I
could just to [ __ ] you know get C's
and B's just to get by you it's tough to
have that discipline later in life yeah
you know what I mean like if you're a
good student you will you know in your
20s you're gonna be focused and stuff I
was never I'm just like
I'll just I was just lazy about it but
then as you get older you realize ah I
gotta have some structure and I that
didn't teach me in school cuz I didn't
care I didn't want to be there I was
just interested you know some of the
stuff I was interested in you know but
most of the stuff I was I'm like I don't
give a [ __ ] this
I'm never gonna need geometry ever in my
life I'm never gonna need algebra I
don't give a [ __ ] about this cuz I've
gotten into an art school when you were
in high school if they had one available
to you like right yeah like right now
where I went to high school they have a
school you go to yeah there's a key as a
communication I school a fall yeah they
do podcasting they do plays they do a
thousand [ __ ] things and they don't
have to take geometry you know would you
have gone to one without a doubt I would
think I didn't know was I want to commit
there was a community college near me
Brookdale Community College and they had
a communications course they had TV dad
acting classes you make your own videos
your TV thing so I was like that's where
I want to go so when I got the college
I'm like this is what I want to do that
radio station is there there you know
local radio state booths on campus to
teach you all that stuff so I loved it
when I got there and that's when I
really start applying myself my get is
what I want to do it does it makes a
huge difference if you're interested in
it if it's something that you enjoy
versus something that you feel like you
have to I always enjoyed movies but I
never saw me in right like I always
enjoyed movies and I had a secret dream
to be in movies but I just never thought
I was good enough to get in them or and
I didn't know where to start
I didn't know anything about an acting
class and about casting people and
nobody ever told me and I was always too
scared to ask I didn't know anything
about it I just knew that I wanted to
get into movies and then when I was 21
or 20 I met John link and he was a
big-time editor he ended it like above
the law commando I met him in Aspen and
I became friendly with him and I would
just tell him put me in a movie and he
would go are you [ __ ] crazy and you
Renaldo I can't put you in a [ __ ]
movie and then I met another friend of
mine who had a friend that was a camera
guy out here so I would torment him but
I never knew anything about this [ __ ] I
didn't know how to get started
who to ask I always thought stand-up
comics called the place and said hey I'm
coming down in take me and then write
specially I didn't know that there was
any work involved I didn't know they had
a workout material I didn't know any of
that [ __ ] I just thought they went down
and didn't Howard just like that just
went home and that's the only time they
would do it I had no idea about what
went into it yeah when I went to their
college I started taking the acting
class and there cuz I'm like I wanted to
be in that kind of my dad was an
accountant and all that stuff and he was
more of a numbers guy and that's what he
wanted me to do I'm like that's not my
thing my brothers in the real estate I'm
like that's not my thing either but when
I saw the acting and the radio and the
TV stuff Oh My gods what I want to do so
I started taking acting classes in
college I mean it helped my buddies that
I grew up with we've all went to the
same school which you know we took the
same classes so we call commuters own
like 20 minutes away from us and then we
every acting scene that we do we always
made sure we can drink in it because we
were [ __ ] know so we'd always have
that championship season I remember was
one where to drink and we always take
scenes where we're [ __ ] getting drunk
cuz you're allowed to do it and if that
was part of the scene so we'd have to
you know to walk back a bud cans [ __ ]
and then we'd be fighting in a lot [ __ ]
so it was great and even that day I
remember to teach a call sounds like
every scene you guys do you guys are
drinking I'm like f we could drink at
school how [ __ ] great is that I
thought he had a bad tooth my buddy
Kevin he had a bad tooth and he bought a
an eight pack of Bud nips into class and
he didn't want to go to the dentist so
he's drinking in the back of the class
is Bud nips to kill the pain in college
and nobody said he had the AP yeah hey
background on the table my mom bud nips
I love those and it's all [ __ ] things
were great six case you got six eight
packs of the case yeah six [ __ ] eight
packs
oh my god I loved those nips and you
know who had a better one course hello
they had the little ones till the little
cans six ounces Oh yet a little yeah I'm
good [ __ ] freeze them they would stay
colder and you could just down in one
[ __ ] and I hate beer yeah I hate beer
back then really that's all we trying I
would buy a pack of Coors and just crack
it and just drink it at one [ __ ] sip
didn't even taste like being
that's why I always love Colorado when I
taste it cause I'm like wait a second I
gotta get out the [ __ ] Colorado they
know what the [ __ ] nice day so cuz but
why Budweiser makes the 8 ounce nips
Miller made them - yeah they dead Miller
Hannah's [ __ ] horrible horrible beer
but the best beer a slight nits is
lowbrow long brow the old brow used to
mate with that tin foil on the [ __ ]
cats are good friends tonight is kind of
special our brow so what the [ __ ] you
doing in town really cranky yeah crank X
is coming back after 12 years on Comedy
Central that's cool we had a run from
2002 to 2007 and get canceled and it's
not with you Jimmy Kimmel Adam Carolla
they started this show because they
worked they were on the man show at the
time so the man show was kicking ass on
Comedy Central and they go hey we have
an idea to do prank calls I'm recreating
with puppets so they gave him sick
Comedy Central Game six episodes right
off the bat guaranteed him which is rare
before it even had said a guy and then
they heard my [ __ ] on Howard Starks I
had these prank calls said mess with
Tamra with Telemark as he was playing
them like we want that dude to be on our
show and I remember my manager telling
me go hey man they want this his new
show on Comedy Central gonna make prank
calls with puppets and they like your
call said I want you to be part of it
I'm like that's [ __ ] that's probably
the worst idea ever all's I thought
about as my comic friends making fun of
me that I'm gonna be on this show it's
gonna be [ __ ] horrendous he's like
look the guaranteed six out I go I'll do
it but I'm gonna get [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
all I thought and the show just took off
and I was the only unknown comic to do
it everybody you know they just heard my
[ __ ] like you know it was Sarah
Silverman Jimmy Adam Carolla Dave
Chappelle Tracy Morgan Wanda Sykes
you know Dane Cook Denis Leary Dave
Attell Kevin Nealon and I was like that
like I was plucked out of obscurity at
that time and that [ __ ] my career
just took off from that just from making
prank calls I could be wrong but that
was like my height of like Comedy
Central back then was the channel it
seemed like it was huge because we were
on right after South Park right before
Jon Stewart so it was a perfect spot on
Tuesday nights that was a big nose big
show I love that show
so you have 12 years later they just
decided it's gonna come back 20 episodes
on Comedy Central I was out here the
[ __ ] 20 episodes so I just did a whole
recording session just the other day out
here I'm gonna go back through some more
but cuz I do two characters on the show
so it's [ __ ] great I'm like I'm a
middle-aged man making prank phone calls
I was burping another phone two days ago
drinking a diet coke and burping and I'm
like this is [ __ ] this is beautiful
how is my son ever gonna go to college
how can either this young ago the Union
energy education it's great now they
gotta bring back the heavy metal show
right so I'm hoping cuz Viacom's
bringing back all these old shows I can
MTV and all the stuff because they
realized that they just you know got rid
of all these shows oh pretty popular and
then put new [ __ ] on they have none of
those shows have gotten ratings in years
so now MTV Comedy Central and hopefully
vh1 does it at some point brings back
shows that actually got ratings so you
never know if that then that that metal
show comes back cuz I was part of Viacom
family on vh1 they just got rid of it
dumped it and you know as a corporate
thing Viacom is losing a ton of money
Nickelodeon was their cash cow and kids
just started watching [ __ ] cartoons
and iPads and and [ __ ] like that so they
stopped watching there and that was it
and then when Jon Stewart left and then
was Stephen Colbert left that hour or
you know whatever that window to Comedy
Central's ratings just went in the
[ __ ] and that was part of Viacom so
when they came in they just got rid of
the whole vh1 classic channel and our
show was the only original show on there
so it wasn't because we weren't getting
ratings they just needed to make major
cuts how long was the heavy metal show
on twelve years right no it was on for
eight years 130 episodes we did it was
insane it's the greatest because they
were just it was the only original
program so it's just on constant leave
like if you look at truTV Impractical
Jokers is on all day all night and
that's the exposure we got on vh1
classic so it was perfect for us because
we were constantly on TV every time you
turn that we you know there was another
show on which slash or whoever we had
that's awesome yeah so but look I mean
that's you know it's an obscure the
music is not that popular so couldn't be
on a regular Channel couldn't be on Fox
that a voice well you know if we're
interview and you know la guns or
something like that that's it's a small
market for that so that channel was
perfect was a little shitty channel
channel like 361 on vh1 on your you know
Direct TV no one bothered us there no
one give it gave a [ __ ] there's no more
music shows though really on TV yeah you
got the voice though all that [ __ ] right
but yeah I want to see that as much as I
want to see [ __ ] point you don't say
I don't want to see that yeah you know I
grew up on the Midnight Special
I grew up on Don Kirshner's rock concert
I grew up on [ __ ] American Bandstand
they had time for all these type of
shows Soul Train
how long was [ __ ] Soul Train Soul
Train stolen down but no Don Cornelius
is dead Murray yeah but now it's like I
want to see a show where they they just
got rid of what's-his-name show that
name he just taped his last show there
that was a music show young bands at
night NBC Oh Carson Daly Carson Daly
right he do it yeah he's gone well do
you think cuz before it used to be like
18 to 36 was the the big age group you
needed to get do you think it's getting
older like maybe like 28 to 48 like like
those people who still have cable and
like those are the people who used to
watch Crank Yankers and we're gonna
watch it again now that it's coming back
out I think maybe like the young kids
they're just like they're not watching
TV so let's make stuff for people who
actually are but you know for band
release of video they'll still get like
you know 3 million views in a day and a
half if they're popular you know it's on
YouTube yeah they're watching so people
are still watching it you know big like
why would you make a video anymore no
one's watching they are I mean you you
look at like the Slipknot has a new
video out there's 45 million views after
a week you know so you people will still
see it but I think it's I think you know
musics not important to people's lives
it's way too many distractions if we had
these phones when we were kids we
probably wouldn't have been in the heavy
metal we wouldn't be sitting in on a
Friday night reading the back of the
lyrics of a Black Sabbath record because
we were bored we had nothing else to do
they got so much distraction on that
phone they don't give a [ __ ] about music
you know any because they got this just
too much just too much information there
there's too much entertainment on that
so the
musics not important to people anymore
so that's why there's no there's not
gonna be a music show cuz nobody get
really gives a [ __ ]
you know the young generations like I
had sis music whatever or not look I you
know I could text my you know six of my
friends right now we're on a mass tax
just [ __ ] bullshitting back and forth
if I don't go to Dorfman from Nashville
was telling me he wants to see the
Grateful Dead in Boulder it was just a
bunch of rich rich kids with dead shirts
on didn't know the music didn't know
anything it's like Coachella a bunch of
people go to those shows they don't know
what's going on and they just go to walk
around they pay a thousand bucks the
averages for those [ __ ] tickets they
do whatever drugs they do and they just
[ __ ] walk around I don't know I don't
know what happened to music I can't put
you know it's listen I'm I'm happy for
guns and roses like I'm happy for all
those bands that are still torrid but
isn't it [ __ ] weird dirty is later I
mean this is it
we have Guns and Roses that's it I mean
you want to see Bob Seger John's making
this goodbye [ __ ] tour run but in
banja touring I mean that's the only way
for them to make money they're making a
fortune VIPs now that yet I heard the
figure that kiss made so far this year
yeah they the first leg or a second
verse like I like 57 million like yet a
gross like over a million dollars a
night now all the bands are doing the
VIP packages if you want to meet them
because they're not getting the record
sales anymore you know so they're not
getting that money from from everyone
buying a million people bands would sell
a million copies in the first week you
know they'd be hit plateau gold that
puts his 500,000 sales every like Judas
Priest would put a record out in 1986
within two weeks it was already they
sold 500,000 now the only bands will
sell 500,000 or a million records so
like Kanye jay-z the Foo Fighters and
you know a couple of the bands that's it
no one sells that many records
you're lucky to sell a hundred thousand
when you would sell two million
you're lucky to sell 250,000 so they
charge extra for the tickets that's why
the concert / tickets are so much and
they have a bi
if you want to meet the man before get a
picture with them sometimes old they'll
do you can go to the soundcheck Sabbath
had a thing last tour the last tour
where you can watch the soundcheck it
was part of a VIP package yesterday
would do but they play like three songs
which is great I mean I knew to be I got
hooked up so me and Jim Norton went and
we watch the soundcheck my might as I
took my son to see the soundcheck he
[ __ ] saw her Iron Man it was me Jim
doors my son and like five other people
is [ __ ] great so that's that's how to
make it money these bands but that's why
all these bands are out there you know
because there's so much money to be made
so they're gonna keep touring all these
old bands like holy [ __ ] look at this I
guess Elton John I paid 350 bucks for a
ticket Bob Seger I paid 310 were you
looking forward to see this summer it's
coming around yeah you know I've seen
everybody a million times I'm getting at
a point where you know Rob Zombie and
Marilyn Manson tour tour and I'll see
that I'm a big Slipknot fan I really
like the energy in that band I've been
and my son loves them it's his favorite
bands we're gonna go see them I'm gonna
go see Ted Nugent is playing right near
my house uncle Ted wet he's playing at
the Starland Ballroom in Sayreville New
Jersey oh [ __ ] yeah yeah so I can't wait
I saw him about two years ago he's great
he doesn't really talk politics in a
show you know he says but it's just
[ __ ] you know opens up what you know
free-for-all goes into dog-eat-dog
[ __ ] it's phenomenal it was less than
we thought about two years ago I saw the
movie Kings in New York City and he was
for the humble phenomenal so great and
you go to see the stones going to see
the stones yes all right they don't -
playing MetLife Stadium where the Giants
and Jets drop for the tickets I didn't
get a ticket yet to play in two nights
so I'll just you know I'll get him the
couple the day of or I looked last week
there yeah you go on StubHub I'll get
them I usually get tickets off StubHub
you know get them there and then you
know a couple days before or whatever so
yeah I'm gonna go see just I saw the
stones already but you know there's
still mix 75 so I'm gonna go see them
I'm gonna see Slipknot corn and Alice in
Chains a tour in this summer so I'll
probably go see that show nothing that
really sticks out for me I know Joe
who's Judas Priest out with or they're
not there did they're doing a bunch of
fast
balls are just as special damn North
Carolina there's a new band that I saw
down in North Carolina I like this band
called dirty honey tore out of Los
Angeles their cross routine like old
Aerosmith a little Zeppelin and Guns and
Roses they just have an EP out they're
really good I saw them at some festival
a couple of weeks ago got some heat they
only got five songs out but they got
that old school sound the key is what
like there's a bank rent a van fleet
that sounds like Zeppelin if the young
kids can get into these these new rock
bands cuz the kid the guys are young in
the band of 21 22 if this new generation
of kids can get into it that will bring
that music that music back right now you
got a bunch of middle-aged dudes going
to watch 20 year olds play [ __ ] that
sounds like Zeppelin you're not getting
that younger generation not getting it
17 18 year old kids then I rent the band
Greta Van Fleet or selling like 6,000
tickets they sell out in two seconds or
whatever and as all these other young
bands so if you get that young
generation into that right the rock
music will come back you need that
because someone's gonna have to do that
like it's just you know when you go see
guns arose yeah maybe you'll bring your
kid because they know Paradise City and
welcome to the jungle but that's what
that's when we're growing up you know
all the broad my older brothers got me
into that stuff so we got into it young
you know ac/dc and going all those shows
but right now any new band that's coming
out that's got some heat that's pretty
good it's just middle-aged dudes going
to sing I went to bands I like I still
love music I mean 60 percent of my day
is music the way I'm music under the
house or whatever but for me going to
conscious was the social thing like hey
it was performed my buddies and we plan
it and we got a bag of reefer and God
knows what else
it was a social thing yeah I know again
now I'm gonna go see the stones maybe up
and Pasadena in August I'm not sure yet
but I don't know if it's that much of a
social thing for kids anymore like we
were up on that like I went to see
Prince for 15 bucks at a club like the
kids I grew up with were into that I had
kids I had friends that that's what they
did like Maurice your Alvarado
that's what he does he goes to concerts
every night he goes to see whoever he
don't give a [ __ ] if it's a Rita
Franklin Def Leppard Devo punk you know
when you're just a fan of music like I
was a fan of music you said something
interesting that was earlier growing up
you had the jocks in the heads I grew up
with jock heads like we lifted weights
we ran we ate good but we also snorted
coke and [ __ ] smelly I see we'd had
an hour and I wanted to concerts like we
were one of those people we we would
lift before we go to a concert again
we're gonna lift till six go home take a
shower and then go to the concert gonna
Grandma blow like we did all that [ __ ]
but we were combination head jocks like
there was no heads and that they didn't
like the jocks now we smoke dope and we
[ __ ] tackled people yeah we know is
the jocks and the burnouts a burnout
yeah they call the guys had smoked
outside the smoking section in between
class who we were to burnout so we were
guys with the Ozzie shirts and the Judas
pretty shirts and then the jocks were
two guys that all played sports and they
usually got the hot chicks we get some
of those burnout chicks there would be a
couple you know it came from a broken
home you know what I mean and like I
call you know and there wasn't that many
of them but you know so but the jocks
always got the hot chicks and we're just
you know we're we're in concert shirts
every every day to school and you know
no girls like yeah I don't even know
what Judas Priest is you're just weird
how did you show us they were crazy
Keith it was great I loved Kate house
crazy Kate doing this she says she's
doing she seems very zen she seems like
she you know now I love Kate man I got a
special place in my heart for does she
[ __ ] she's out there you know what I
mean busting her ass every night she's
like a dude she just [ __ ] I don't
give me a stage
give me a stage no problem I'll do my
jokes doesn't [ __ ] just low-maintenance
she sees it for what it is yeah low
maintenance on the road does it's it's a
guide if this is what I got to deal with
this what I got to deal with you know
hecklers whatever so yeah it was great
you know wouldn't you go back to the big
bed function Apple I'm going back
tomorrow all tonight on the red-eye
let's go back I gotta say it sure would
say I'm Tripoli tonight we're doing some
I don't know some naughty show thing
somewhere you know hit a red I got my
boy tomorrow lets it hang out it's
[ __ ] great yeah and what do you build
for the sub beside these shows you gonna
show it all yeah we got a family
vacation in Long Beach Island we rent
the house every year our family got one
like right on the beach we all chip in
the 7 of us and all the kids there all
of stuff
no no parents but you know my brothers
and sisters their kids you know so it'll
be the first year my mom passed away in
November 80 years old said I was like
you know this would be the first
vacation without her which you show you
know she always loved it and helped run
and all that stuff but you know but yeah
it's gotten the kids you know the beach
is right there we're in Long Beach
Island they got the [ __ ] rides and
all that [ __ ] so it's gonna be great and
the concerts and then my boys will just
hang out you know I don't put them in a
camp or anything like that I'm like no
you play with your friends on the [ __ ]
block you wake up at 9 in the morning
I'll see you in a few hours you hang on
my house they hang out their house like
that it's [ __ ] great they got
sleepovers and all a [ __ ] you know
they're in my basement going crazy how
old's your boy then he's eight it's
turning nine yeah that's a great [ __ ]
crazy age oh yeah whoo I have fireworks
this year yeah I got you know they'll
actually sell them at the Walmart in in
Jersey they'll sell now like the crazy
stuff a lot of [ __ ] that shoots in the
air so you buy a whole thing of like a
hundred bucks and what blow at will you
know shoot the stuff up in here he loves
it yeah yes sir wait till it's night
time we shoot it up so we got a bunch of
it all time he loves a quarter [ __ ]
stick yeah I don't know probably not you
know like a pack of five or something
would be like 35 35 cents exactly it was
like 20 25 yeah I bang him out for a
dollar the sticks with 50 cents bang him
for a dollar we buy a big bag of weed
off this dude yeah yeah my brother's
friend was dealing in high school he
would just come on a brown bag or just
weed and just be you know selling it to
people right in the hallway and then we
buy and then we roll up joints and we
sold the joints for three bucks
you know me we'll make like two bucks on
the joints we'd sell ten for you know
you know could be like uh mom and I'm
like hey man it's ten joints $22 usually
a joint was a dollar holiday yeah so we
get like 22 bucks for
joints dude you're gonna bite off some
guy in the street you're gonna go to New
York to get this [ __ ] you know yeah it
was a [ __ ] mother and then we'd walk
to 7-eleven with a bottle of Southern
Comfort and drinking along the way and
go buy porno magazines yeah high school
yeah grammar school around 8th 9th 10th
grade smoke my first we to 12 years old
I was at a concert and they were passing
along as they did it just passed it
along my brother's with me I'm like a
nice IKEA right I'm [ __ ] I was high
at 12 it's beautiful
what date you got coming up anything
good uncle Vinny's June 1st Point
Pleasant New Jersey were talking about
there before and I'll see you all gets
to be around yeah I'm gonna be around
going back to Jersey so August I only
fly in that day yeah in DC that Friday
so I don't even get that I think yeah
that's Bobby down there um I'm gonna
come down and I you're in August 10th
and my comedy special I got the house is
out whether that's come on that came out
a couple months ago he could stream it
on Amazon Prime or it's on iTunes it's
all about my divorce and you released it
yourself I released it myself for you
you don't need to own the whole [ __ ]
thing yeah you don't need that doesn't
matter I tell people it's everywhere but
Netflix and I don't care like if I can't
get a Netflix deal it doesn't matter and
you own your [ __ ] you know how much
money you're gonna make on this ship
when you own it five ten years from now
people [ __ ] will find you you know
they'll find it they everybody can find
it and my podcasts is every Monday
comedy mental midgets
that's the podcast no that's what it's
called my podcasts called comedy mental
midgets when I my serious show is called
mental [ __ ] what is a serious show
come on every Thursday okay
and they replayed a few times donor
weeks I'm lost but I usually catch I'm
serious and like I said last Sunday I
caught it and you played something
tremendous by priests I was like [ __ ]
that's tremendous I feel about it I
think that was one of the one of the
song from the live album Unleashed nice
to do though I think it was all maybe
running wild something you played it was
something priests eat right but [ __ ] it
always a pleasure to have you thank you
man thank you very much for coming up
I want to thank jim Florentine for
coming on the show and don't forget
[ __ ] tickets all more
sold out for June first at the Ice House
working out with uncle Joey we also have
the Fillmore theater New Orleans on June
7th and the Tabernacle Theatre in
Atlanta Georgia on June 8 tickets still
available for the Fillmore theater in
New Orleans and for the 8th at the
Tabernacle come on down [ __ ] I want
to give a shout out to our sponsors the
church is brought to you by manscape
listen uncle Joey's here to tell you
something the suffering ends now you've
asked your girlfriend or your wife to
trim the [ __ ] bush around your dick
or your ball sack you're sitting there
looking up in the air waiting to [ __ ]
get killed because without you dick
that's where you feel you feel like
you're dead well the suffering ends
today ok with manscape you get it done
without the pain and anxiety you're like
why Joey why I tell you why because they
got precision tools for the Family
Jewels you [ __ ] [ __ ] manscaped
has redesigned the electric razor
they've invention it's called the lawn
mower a handheld razor with skin safe
technology so it won't Nick or snag your
nutsack you got to go easy on what what
the [ __ ] Lord gave you right you
don't want to show up with a dick would
[ __ ] bruises on it and stitches this
[ __ ] like this this bad boy will leave
your area nice clean smooth pain and
anxiety free plus it's rechargeable and
easy to hold so you get into all the
nooks and crannies by your [ __ ] and
under your nutsack so there's no
misunderstandings manscape will get your
beanbag looking as smooth as a [ __ ]
egg you understand me and I'm gonna let
you in on a little secret if you trim
the hedges the [ __ ] love stick looks
a lot bigger now what are you waiting
for trim up that [ __ ] dick of yours
at manscape calm they'll give you
everything you need to make your balls
shine your dick look bigger and your
dick look pretty like it's going to the
Oscars when was the last time you got a
dick ready for the Oscars you have it
with manscaped it looks like your dick
is going to the Oscars and if this is
the first time he's confused considered
manscaping they got a deal for you you
ready they got something called the
perfect package it comes with a
lawnmower and a safety razor plus the
crop reserved especially for
deodorant so your balls don't stink like
a [ __ ] dead animal and the Reviver
you keep them in the car little packages
it spritz that tones and refreshes your
nutsack and your dick bowl to keep you
nice and clean in the summertime you
understand me and right now the church
family can get 20% off your first order
when you use promo code Church CH you
are CH at manscape comm and if you are
the perfect package to also throw in a
free travel bag when you use promo code
Church CH you are CH so go to manscape
com use promo code Church so I'm gonna
give you 20% off your first order and
you're gonna get the perfect package
you're gonna be tip-top Magoo for the
rest of the year you understand me
you're gonna be getting dates women are
gonna enjoy sucking your dick and
looking in that sack why because at
manscape com that's what this driving
for mobile more [ __ ] and let stinky
[ __ ] dicks
now keep your balls clean but it starts
with manscape calm the church is also
brought to you by on it why Joey why do
you like on it so much why because their
supplements are clean Bobby
they got [ __ ] bats they got
kettlebells I can't help you with that
as far as the supplements the protein
powders the beef jerky the jerky the
[ __ ] ultra the shroom Tex immune the
shrimp tank [ __ ] what's the other one
sport sport which will give you more
oxygen true honor is the way to go let
me say it alpha brain give you a little
cloudy you're feeling like you can't
focus
give alpha brain a [ __ ] challenge you
understand me give him a little try if
you don't like it they give you a
hundred percent money-back guarantee and
they don't want the product who else
does that nobody that's why I deal with
on it and that's why I suggest you going
on if you're looking for these type of
supplements do me a favor go to high
Netcom right now and look at the great
selection that they have whether it's
protein you need whether it's Tamela
talk whatever you need they got the oil
for the [ __ ] coffee they got it all
go to Anna calm right now you find some
you like press in charge and get 10% off
delivery right the
[ __ ] crib you don't even gotta leave
the house all right so I want to thank
manscape
I want to thank on it but most
importantly I want to thank you guys on
Memorial Day for making this podcast
[ __ ] a savage that it is and most
importantly for listening and for
supporting this so I want to thank Jimmy
I want to thank the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but I want to thank you [ __ ]
for always being solid I'll see you back
here Thursday morning ready to rock it's
the end of the month [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] together if you're gonna be alive
this is the week to do it now go get
yourself one kick this [ __ ]
mealy